je vais vous raconter un grand histoire
jean t n o coste n'y a pas de doute
c'est aujourd'hui cette année annonce
hervé magnin jamais sa beauté et les
faits les règles sont pour leurs frais
que c'est vraiment un truc de malade
mental alors tu sais quoi je ne
cherchais pas et je vais démonté la
gueule c'est qu'ici je m'appelle j'y
paiement on était ensemble
non depuis cinq ans on a rendez vous le
25 juillet tracé concerne j'ai teint
avec nous on a toujours dit qu'on
prenait pour les petites copines à peu
près tous d'accord affirme
à schaerbeek à l'allemand rien foutu de
ma gueule d'après n'importe quel train
ou à l'efb la turquie fasse n'importe
quoi oui
ça peut durant que tu fais c'est du
tourisme à la casse couilles de l'otan
le sol est devant la rivière derrière et
moi au milieu des mutins mais me
04 et guitare des nues j'aime pas